Announcing ThinkerCon, remember several years ago five of us educational content creators got together and we did this live events
It was really fun, but people came from like 40 states and 12 different nations for it
So clearly there's a lot of demand for this sort of thing. We're gonna do something similar only much bigger
There were five content creators at that event
There's going to be 20 times that at what we're doing here and they're not just youtubers. They're
podcasters makers artists
explorable content online people that make
educational content for the masses it's a celebration of
Educational content which is something we need in the world today ThinkerCon has all the information you need Hotel
Information where to fly in to November 17 2018 a one-night celebration of educational content online
I apologize if there are no tickets left by the time you get to the website
This is gonna be a really cool night. For example, there's a Saturn 5 rocket hanging from the ceiling
We're gonna feed you a full-on German meal under that rocket will explain the German bit. Later
But you can do that and then after that you can go down to the amphitheater
There's gonna be a really cool variety show hosted by the festival the spoken nerd from the UK
You can come back in under the rocket and hang out with some of the other educational content creators in the rooms
There's people from all over the internet that do all different types of educational content
Which is really cool because YouTube is sponsoring the event now one of the top priorities for YouTube is education
So I think it's cool that they're sponsoring event where people are just doing education online. So I'll let Malik explain this to you
He's the head of global education at YouTube. Check us out. Yeah, I'm not used to be on camera
so, this is Malik Ducard is the
Global head of education at YouTube and they've agreed to sponsor ThinkerCon. Thank you very much. Oh we're thank you
Look, we're incredibly excited enthusiastic about ThinkerCon
We're happy to sponsor it
We're just really really believe in the
educational community on
YouTube and ThinkerCon is just going to be such a great gathering of that community
So yeah, we are exited
well people don't realize that you do a lot of stuff behind the scenes like we're in we're in Rio right now for an
Educational contend creator event. Yeah, but people don't see that
Yeah, so the cool thing about ThinkerCon is people will get to see the contribution that YouTube makes to education in general. Yeah.
Well, we're excited to be part of that. Thank you so much. So, thank you very much YouTube
This is gonna be a really big educational content celebration. There is a lot of big names coming to this event
So we'll put some of their logos on the website, but just know that that's not everybody that's coming
There's even more than is on the website
there's a forum at the bottom of the ThinkerCon web page if you're like an
Institution or a university or a company fill out the form. We'll see if we can get you connected with some cool people
I really want to end the event with a chemical
Fireworks show basically meaning we're gonna like shoot a color and talk about the chemistry in that color
No promise is on the firework show
I gotta get that approved with the city on behalf of all the content creators involved in this this is not just a Destin thing
This is all of us banding together to try to promote educational content throughout the internet
We hope to see you in Huntsville at the first ever ThinkerCon,
ThinkerCon 2018 is the first of its kind and man they really hope they let me do the fireworks thing
Anyway, go get your tickets Thanks. Bye